oh  and there it is right at the corner but  your account hit away from losing your  account oh my god that was so smart  three  that was so smart didn't press anything  big it's the rage drive wait a minute  the blue stuff  and just steal back turn lows goes for  the normal throw we saw it worth one  round not going to work this time spins  the blue all goes for the slide 17  seconds goes for the fake out no brain  works  two  now massive health lead  wow  wow  one  some traction now  downforce the down four one try to go  for the down another one it's not gonna  work and harada cares  he's gonna fully charge it no he does  not  shoeshine  ready with the bonjour oh my god  [Music]  [Music]  you